hello and welcome back now in our
previous lesson we unlocked two
achievements that are fairly easy to get
the first timer achievement you get for
playing the game and they Otton a UTI
prey achievement that you get for making
a not particularly good guess and while
it's easy to earn these achievements if
you actually want to test earning these
achievements multiple times it's kind of
difficult to do because you know you
can't earn them again you already have
them and that brings us to the topic of
the games management ap is now as you
recall we provide a lot of rest
endpoints for you to unlock achievements
or increment achievements or submit
scores to leaderboards and so on and so
forth we also provide a set of
restricted endpoints that allow you to
for instance remove a player scores from
the scoreboard or hide a particular
player who's you know potentially a
cheater
from appearing in the public leaderboard
or in this particular case we give you
the ability to reset an achievement to
its original state
now these management api's are very
powerful and you know you don't want
them falling into the wrong hands and so
the one restriction around them is that
they can only be called in your
application by people you have listed as
testers so remember if we go back here
to the developer console and we click on
this little testing link only the people
who are added here will be able to make
these calls which you know if you think
about it kind of makes sense you don't
want your average player to be able to
you know reset their achievements they
would probably be very mad if you know
somehow they accidentally did that and
so in my case because I am testing with
my development account I will be able to
make these calls pretty easily now how
do we make these calls if you've been
investigating the library at all or you
know viewing the documentation or
playing around with the autocomplete you
might notice that we have a couple of
pretty nifty functions let me go into my
achievement manager here for instance
once you have a GPG achievement you
actually call will call unlock me reset
achievement with completion Handler and
and this would make a call to our
management api's and say you know hi
please reset the this particular
achievement for this player and the
results will you pass back in this
completion handler similarly we also
have we have a class method GPG
achievement reset all achievements with
completion Handler and this does the
same thing except that it basically
resets all achievements for the player
and you know this seems like this is
pretty useful right you can kind of I
could hook up a button within my app may
be called QA debugging that brings up
another view controller that has few
buttons that you know would would link
to a reset all achievements method and
reset my scores
you know leaderboards method and so on
and so forth there's just one tiny
little problem which is that these calls
don't work right now the team knows
about it they have promised me that
there will be a fix in an upcoming
version of the library however that's
not available here for my screencast and
that makes me sad but only a little sad
because you know what we can still make
these calls the old-fashioned way by
directly accessing the rest endpoints so
let's do that this will be kind of a fun
little you know refresher course on how
to make these rest calls so first thing
let's delete this keep our code nice and
tidy now the first thing we're gonna
need to do is get our access token to
make this call and so I can go back into
my game view controller or sorry my
intro view controller here and you'll
notice this is where you know I
commented out this section where i blog
hey here's our auth object but let's go
ahead and get our access token back so
we can make some authorize some calls
outside of our game so you know what
first thing i'm gonna scroll up to the
top here and i'm going to import google
open source / google open source eh and
now i'm gonna go down and here and if
there's no error
log our access token is this string and
we'll call off dot access token let's
run this
and you can see right here in our
console I now have an access token that
I can use so I'm going to copy this and
the next thing I'm going to do is bring
up my terminal or I turn and I'm gonna
make a curl call so if you're on an OSX
device
you know it's Linux based and so you
have this nifty little utility called
curl that allows you to basically access
pages or other resources over HTTP
directly so I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
curl HTTP Google API is comm slash game
slash v 1 slash players slash me slash
achievements and our access token
oops sorry it should be access token
there yum equals this thing and here we
have a list of our achievements and
their current status we've got a couple
that are unlocked one that's revealed
but not earned and another that's
revealed but not earned but we've made
some steps towards completing it this
one is very clearly are sent to guess or
achievement by the way in case you're
wondering wait how did I know you know
what this giant URL is it's in our
documentation so if you were to go to go
to developers.google.com slash game
slash services you can go out of the web
here look at REST API reference and
here's a bunch of calls you can get so
under achievements achievement list was
actually the call that I made and you
can see you know here's the URL game
slash P 1 slash players the player ID in
this case entering me just means the
player who is making this call as
identified by the access token and this
will list the achievements now this is
good but this lesson is really about the
management api's so we're gonna look at
this management API reference and under
here under achievements we have a couple
of methods reset and reset all so let's
look at this so if we want to reset a
specific key
it looks like we can do that by making a
post call here and passing in some data
where our achievement ID equals the
achievement ID it's a string so now
let's pick one that we actually want to
reset according to all right so this one
ending an AE is our Auton a UTI prey
achievement yours is probably different
but we can look at this and figure out
the call to make so I'm gonna make a
curl call let's move that over okay to
HTTPS dub dub dub Google API is comm
slash game slash V 1 management again
that's V 1 management not V 1 / T mints
/ and it's this thing ending in AE /
reset and our access token equals this
thing we had copied and pasted earlier
and then we also need to pass in the
same achievement ID you can see here has
data in our post call and we can do that
just by adding - D achievement ID equals
and then we paste back in this thing we
enter that and it tells us oh okay
looks like that achievement is now
hidden and again if we were to list our
achievements directly we can see that we
now have our reveals not earned revealed
incremental and unlocked and him and
let's look at our reset all and this one
looks even easier we're just making a
call to achievement / reset so I'm going
to you know what can just copy and paste
this oops it's giving me a not found
error probably because I did not put in
pass in my access token
equals
and again we can paste in this access
token that we got from a console oh I
guess we're still getting an error and
okay this is because Carl is by default
sending this as a get and if you'll
notice this call is actually a post
request so I think I can force this to
be a post just by adding some like data
here yeah there we go and it sends back
by the way which achievements have now
been reset so it looks like we had two
other achievements our incremental
achievement and our first-timer
achievement that have been reset now and
again if I were to do a quick look at
our achievements we can see they are all
now back in their initial state so let's
go back to our app by the way if I were
to click achievements right now my guess
is yeah it's cached in this data it
doesn't know that anything's changed yet
so it'll still give us this not
unexpected so the best thing to do is
just you know we'll quit this run it
again get the force to the library to
fetch new data and now we can look at
our achievements and I can once again
see that they're empty and alright you
know now we can go about making sure
that we've earned them correctly so we
can now go ahead and I'm gonna guess 50
again and we still get the Ahtna okay I
pray achievement that is now freshly
unlocked and you know we could do this
again any time our tester needs to go
through the QA plan and so digging up
your access token making this curl call
not hugely convenient but still you know
pretty easy to do particularly if you're
a developer and I'm guessing most of you
are there are a few other ways we could
do this the other will be to wait for
this library to be fixed and build your
own in-game interface again once there's
an update to the library I will post a
screencast that shows you exactly how to
do that it should also be noted that if
you were to look at our downloads page
there's a link to a utility called
management tools and this is an
application that can make all of these
manage
API calls for you this is something that
you would set up and run say on
localhost you're on your own web server
and basically it just automates grabbing
your access token and making these rest
calls on on your behalf
you know without your having to enter
them in in you know manually as a curl
call so I encourage you to check this
out this would be particularly useful
for development it also contains some
tools you might want to use post-launch
for you know some community support and
maybe if there's enough interest I'll
create a series of screencasts on this
as well but hey let's not get too
distracted we have other iOS stuff to
finish first we've gotten our
achievements and we've gotten them
working and we've shown you how to earn
them how to increment them how to reset
them so you can test them again but we
haven't done anything with our
leaderboards now luckily most of the
process for leaderboards is fairly
similar to what we did with achievements
so this next section should be pretty
easy so stay tuned and I'll see you in
the next lesson bye